do you think who do you think's smarter
men or women women women women
then why are so many of us and only fans
because why are so many men
more guys
who's the female Elon Musk Bill Gates
where are they we're so smart
okay we don't give we don't we're not
given the chance
I mean you could say that all you want
okay that's just the fact and this is
all women right here mine I don't
because I've been giving them plenty of
them okay so I've been in the I've been
in the deployment recruiting space for
28 years women have a higher Advantage
getting a job over a man more black
women have degrees in Black Men the
first millionaire woman in America was
black
right self-made women have more of
advantages than men to be successful
right so I don't know where and going
back to the only fans 92 percent of the
people on only fans are women not men
yeah because we know who's paying
exactly so but only fans doesn't have to
be just nudity you could take advantage
of this person I agree I agree because
initially I mean you could but we don't
like I did I mean initially when you
have to get mood I didn't have to sleep
with them what'd you what'd you do on
only fans I took cute pictures of her
feet
I did that as well okay so you so you
were
still not taking off your clothes but
they're not they're not looking at the
only fans to be your friend well they're
looking for something that's what only
fans of sports for exclusive content so
if I don't post on my Instagram or my
Facebook pictures and swimsuits cute
short dresses or whatever that is still
selling sex but it's from a different
perspective well yeah but I'm saying
you're still selling Beauty and I'm
saying if we're so smart why don't we
sell brains you can do this
because they're usually not beautiful
why aren't they selling more Beauty I
just think that like women are not going
to pay for it like and like on only fans
uh when a man actually has only fans
account more gay men are actually
purchasing their their content than it
is women because we're we're not going
to pay for it yeah no yeah but I'm
saying like if we're just these smart
people it's like we could go into
physics
smarter not harder if you know you can
just take cute pictures
I think you're right women love the easy
women love the easy way not the hard way
and we just get naked instead of doing
the hard thing and maybe I don't have
the opportunity to do that that's why
they have to work hard because nobody's
going to pay them correct correct and
that's why I think men are smarter than
us because they have to do I think when
you have to do harder things you become
smarter you know like if if you if you
have to study for a test and then you
have to take the test you become smarter
isn't it really true that the person who
didn't have to study and still got an A
is smarter than the one who had the book
their balls and that would be great if
we were good if we were getting A's I
would agree through school but it's so
funny it's so funny because we actually
aren't doing even though we have an
advantage because we can sell Beauty
it's so funny we make like 500 a month
on only fans on average we can't even
sell sex the women that make the most
money on only fans are managed by men if
we were so smart why can't even we why
can't we sell our own bodies better than
men they're making AI Bots yeah AI Bots
yeah and so it's like if we were really
so smart why can't we figure out how to
do it go ahead
um I happen to know a lot of the people
that work for managing of people they're
gay guys gay guys are nasty they know
how to [__] talk they know exactly
what people wanted I promise you
the people that you're talking to are
gay men all right but they're still men
yeah
but gay men are have the feminine side
they're tapped into their feminine
energy
it's not like a straight-ass men that
are managing and they're responding
there most of them but they're still men
like why like why can't the women figure
it out no they just don't want to they
don't want to talk like that
they're kind of disgusting so they know
what the disgusting [__] that makes
money being able to relate to your
audience of course if men are the ones
in the market buying and stuff then of
course a guy's gonna know what to say
and how to Market it and what kind of
pictures they want shouldn't we know
since we've been like dating men our
whole lives don't we no shouldn't we
know what to say to men like if we're
the ones dating I think our emotions
like kind of get in the way of that
sometimes it's our hormone levels
everything like I mean they even said
like women that are on like birth
control like their hormone levels are
just crazy like you're more neurotic you
are not like almost like not yourself so
I and also that goes with the workforce
when they say oh like women and men are
not paid equally well we have less time
in the workforce because we have more
time off we have to get pregnant we have
periods sometimes people have to go home
and stay home because their periods are
so intense so it almost and men are
smarter I think hold on don't forget
bathrooms they love to like they
actually mention that on that um that
one movie about like the women who are
like you know doing the stuff in space
how like she had to take time to go to a
certain bathroom and how long it takes
us to go to the bathroom as opposed to
men all that stuff is factored as well
yeah that we have to go to the bathroom
for a long time that's holding us back
yeah longer than men they they factor in
20 and 2023. okay if I got a job at this
podcast Studio I think they'd hire me I
really do I think yeah and and I'd have
to walk to the bathroom there that's
gonna hold me back like as women we just
come up with excuses it's like excuse
Excuse excuse We're Men it's like you'll
have a guy in horrible working
conditions like on oil rigs Paving the
Pavements they don't complain women's
yeah yeah and we're we're in um we're in
the office like in these nice cushy jobs
and we still find something to whine
about okay I had a question how many men
do you is what you do you go down a
thousand feet underground and you see
aliens and stuff like that
they do experiments but so no aliens
nuclear stuff too yeah like that how
many how what's the what's a women to
men ratio there are you like the only
woman down there I am probably one of
like
four and there's more scientist women
there but there's but let's talk about
the labors the laborers it's like it's
probably like 99 men there you go yeah
yeah no but it's true they uh so they
did this like they did this like study
like a walking on the street study where
they asked men and women
um would you rather okay so it was like
would you rather work a high profile job
that pays nothing or would you rather
work in the sewers that pays a hundred
thousand dollars a year most women chose
a high profile job that pays nothing and
the men most of the men were like well
no I want the money so I'm going to work
in the sewers so it's like goes to show
you that like most women just kind of
want like to say that we have this great
job this kind of crazy thing but we
don't want to do like the dirty gritty
thing to actually make the money Dirty
Jobs that's how I got my position
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible